[Music]
the ocean is at breaking point radical
steps are needed to preserve the
freshest ecosystems of the sea but can
part of this battle be fought on land
mangroves are evolutionary marvels
they're a critical part of most tropical
oceanic ecosystems but they're rapidly
disappearing one coastal community in
southern Kenya has found a pioneering
way to protect their mangroves turning
the tide on its dwindling forests by
harnessing one of the mangroves most
impressive superpowers kept hidden deep
underground
[Music]
it's early morning and some of the
residents of Ghazi Bay are making their
way deep into the heart of a mangrove
forest
they're here to conduct a health check
on this dense ecosystem let's go there
now that is still Rocking let's look for
us what's here
Lilian is a lead scientist who works
with the local community their forest
cover would you think guys I think
eighty two hundred percents mangroves
grow along tropical coastlines and
they're the only type of tree to thrive
in saltwater where we are can be a bit
deceiving you might assume we are in our
normal terrestrial forest but the tides
influence this place the team has until
noon to carry out its checks before the
forest floor floods with water the
mangroves of gauzy bays stretch out over
six hundred and fifteen hectares but
today the team is only concentrating on
one small patch they are setting out a
10 by 10 plots they're checking the
biomass of the trees and for signs of
new growth that's about seven eighths
about nine meters
mangroves are important for the health
of the ocean the nutrient-rich sheltered
water provides nursery habitats for
numerous marine species another very
important aspect to look at is the
biodiversity so when we come to the
forest we want to see how many crabs do
we have are they within the acceptable
range what kind of species do we have
mangroves also help to keep the ocean
clean they're tangled root system
filters dirty water as it flows into the
sea we are looking at 1.3 meters from
the ground so about here there is no
prop roots above this point so we are
going to take our diameter here but
forests like these have another
superpower that can help tackle one of
the oceans and the planet's greatest
threats climate change
one of the key functions of mangroves is
to act as natural carbon stores and they
are globally significant in that
function mark Hudson is based in
Edinburgh but he spent much of his
career knee-deep in mangrove forests
around the world including in Ghazi Bay
typically mangroves bury and store far
more carbon than terrestrial forests for
example at our site in Kenya they're
somewhere between six and eight times
more carbon buried in the sediment you'd
expect in the soils of a tropical forest
all trees need carbon dioxide to grow as
they absorb it from the atmosphere
carbon becomes locked within the trees
leaves branches and roots parts of the
tree eventually fall off into the soil
where they decompose releasing some of
their co2 back into the atmosphere but
mangroves are different they're tangled
network of roots traps this carbon rich
plant material in their waterlogged soil
sealing it off from the atmosphere this
vault of carbon can remain secure for
millennia
as long as the mangrove forests remain
intact but here's where the problem lies
barely half the world's original
mangroves remain
[Music]
mangroves are being lost around the
world because of human impact in the
past most of that was shrimp farming
removal of trees and a mouthful palm oil
plantation also for coastal developments
like hotels and roads and in Africa in
particular extraction for fuel wood and
for timber so taking a simple projection
of rates of loss all mangroves would
disappear within the next hundred years
[Music]
in Ghazi Bay the community has been
harvesting mangrove wood for centuries
on the whole local people who depend on
their mangrove ecosystems are very well
aware how important they are however the
challenge is to find means of conserving
them particularly to find income that
will fund conservation many people in
the area where we work are extremely
poor and that means relatively small
amounts of money can make a major
difference to their lives mark and a
group of scientists decided to join
forces with the local communities of
Ghazi Bay to create a pioneering
approach to protect the mangrove forests
macoco panocha which means mangroves
together in swahili is the world's first
community-based mangrove conservation
project that's funded by the sale of
carbon credits
and our food when we analyzed for the
organic matter and int and a organic
carbon in this soil it's a good
indicator of how much we continue to
capture and stock with by protecting
this forest they found a way of making
more money out of the forest by keeping
it alive than by cutting it down this is
the major parts of the carbon in a
monkey forest because you can see the
high content their roots in it and a lot
of organic matter so the mangroves do a
lot of this in capturing and storing
organic matter within their soil we
convert the biomass to carbon and we are
able to tell you how much carbon we have
this Forest stores around 1,500 tons of
carbon per hectare this again is further
converted to the carbon dioxide
equivalence which are traded in the
markets they are selling this mangrove
forests ability to sequester carbon on
what is known as the voluntary carbon
credit market individuals and industries
all create carbon emissions especially
in rich countries to try to counter the
damaging effect people can calculate how
many tons of carbon they emit and offset
this by paying carbon capture
initiatives like planting trees that can
remove carbon from the atmosphere it
sounds simple but it's far from perfect
critics of carbon accounting say it's
hard to accurately calculate how much
carbon any one project is sequestering
because there are so many varying
factors to take into account and there
are other concerns too carbon offsetting
is controversial because some people may
be tempted to use it as an excuse for
inaction on the climate emergency and
we're very clear that offsetting is one
small part of our response to what we're
facing in terms of climate breakdown but
it's got to be part of a broader and can
and coherent policy to get to a zero
common world and if done correctly these
carbon credits provide a financial
incentive for communities to stop
harvesting mangroves and start
protecting them the macoco / merger
project is verified to sell over 2,000
carbon credits each year this
corresponds to the extra carbon storage
and sequestration their conservation
insures over the past five years this
has earned the surrounding villages more
than $60,000 which the community has
spent on clean water sources and
supplies for the local clinic and
schools as well as forest rangers who
guard this precious resource and the
initiative is reaping benefits for some
of those who work on the ocean too much
why did you go on your body focus on
women afraid macoco possible until
eternal partner no only una serie my
moment my sorrowful onion save even a
meaty Pokagon available for now was a
model PMI pokorny free ticket to nepata
I will pay you PA etus Amy
it's a silly about some delicate
alliterative on an aside from a panel a
given value known an epoch Infiniti who
are near Caputo sure Kotaku an I in a
Tigger micro some some McEwen attack our
climate change is the overwhelming
challenge of our times and small
projects like this they're only a drop
in the ocean
however if none of us attempt these
projects and nothing will happen
but macoco pamoja is a pioneering model
nearby villages are keen to replicate
its success and in Madagascar a similar
project is already underway we can't
hope to have the kind of world that I
expected when I first started studying
ecology as a 12 year old bird watcher
but that doesn't mean that we can't have
a world full of beauty and wildness but
we have to fight hard for it scientists
are only now starting to understand the
importance of these majestic forests for
the health of the ocean and the planet
pioneers like Lilian and Marc are
changing the relationship between local
communities and these ancient mangroves
it's a model that could help protect
ecosystems way beyond these shores if
you'd like to find out more about the
greatest challenges facing the ocean and
the people trying to solve them then
click on the link opposites or you can
watch more from the protected series by
clicking on the other link don't forget
to subscribe and thank you for watching